okay now we're going to draw some
parallel lines and transversals and then
we're going to have a look at the angles
that come with those okay so now we're
looking at now what happens when you got
these you put these two together you got
the parallel lines and then you kind of
crossed it let's draw one okay now let's
put some labels on this so we can
actually start to talk about this thing
I'll call this one a B this one C D and
this one cute okay now what's the normal
way like you can see I've tried to draw
these parallel but we usually label them
in some way to indicate their power how
do we do that yeah do it so somewhere
along there you put an arrow there and
an arrow here okay and that tells us
right these are never gonna be so here I
can say a B and C D are parallel lines
or they're just parallel okay but that
takes forever to write and you're gonna
be saying these are parallel Lots so
instead we say this a B and then you
literally put two parallel lines right
you say that so these two mean the same
thing
a B and C they're parallel this is our
notation form a B and C D our path
so what's P Q P Q is the transversal
okay yes yeah yeah as in that is like a
geez it is okay now what kinds of angles
are we got here and what patterns can we
take advantage of right well here's one
or two suggest remember to look at the
planets before right and it's like no
one's ever been to that planet how do
they know anything about what that
planet is like well we can do a similar
thing here suppose I should have brought
with me okay
I had a big giant protector I've
actually been yelling one of my
suffering and I measured this angle here
now just if you had to guess what does
it look like what's a reasonable number
for that in degrees it's between oh by
the way we have language this what kind
of angle is it in terms of size its
obtuse right so it's between 90 and 180
how about 120 I looks about right
doesn't it I suppose I could dust it
with it if I measured out like a chapter
right he's the great D here I've
measured what angle but there are one
two three four five six seven eight
angles here and now I know the size of
all of them without measuring anymore
how do I do that how do I just measure
what angle and then I can know the rests
I think you tell me one other angle
actually maybe I should put some more
labels on your call backs can you name
an angle for me and tell me what its
size it
can anyone tell me for instance
what's P X P angle P X P what's that
equal to it so it it goes along a
straight line right Ami's long straight
late angry long straight line they add
up to think back think back they add up
toward a straight line you mean you mean
a X Y yeah okay so that's 60 degrees
there could be opposite you do the same
thing here okay and I could keep going I
can go down to this one in a second okay
but how do we do it
oh well because P choose a straight line
right an x and y on that straight line
angle be XY okay it's not just equal to
it is the same as what did you look at
being X cubed they are actually the same
angle okay so the difference is one of
the arms goes longer but it's them it's
an angle in there that matters okay now
in order to get from here like what did
we use to do that
we knew angles on a straight line and we
knew that vertically opposite there okay
but to get through all of these angles
these fall down to these four we need a
fewer pieces and a few more shapes and
patterns on to recognize okay so
underneath where you draw this diagram
we're going to draw three more okay and
they look like this he's my first one
okay now when you got that it's looking
shape okay and you looking at the two
angles that are nestled up in the
corners okay
these two angles they match together
they're related to each other to pull
away they have a name starts to seize
they don't know what they're very close
it's corresponding okay we're going to
get to code here in a second but these
are called corresponding okay now when
you've got corresponding angles between
parallel lines what can we say about
them what can we say about them what do
they look like oh sure like I mean in
terms of the size of each angle how do
they look in comparison to each other
same as be executed how do they look
they look the same don't they they look
the same and they uh okay corresponding
angles on that's an power though ones
are equal okay
so I can call this 80 degrees and if I
know it's 80 degrees I know the other
ones a breeze as well okay now that was
the F shape zhenia remember there are
other shapes as well that help us
recognize patterns see and well it's an
incident let's do this
actually I'll do the same problem I'll
do the same cuz that's not this okay
these two angles here if I've got
parallel minds okay what do I call these
ones starts with an A alternate angles
okay not to be confused with alternative
angles alternative is a musical style
alternate is about names
okay what's the relationship again what
does it look like they how do they
compare to each other then it's the same
don't they okay alternate angles are uh
sorry on parallel lines are also eat
okay so I call those angles a let's call
this B 3 okay so there's your F which is
your corresponding angles
there's your Z which is your ten fingers
what's the last one it's this it's the C
isn't it now
be careful I'll really draw two
different seas okay and you'll see why
it's a good how do you make it you out
all I see what you mean okay you can you
can draw that pose do this step you now
probably most of you will draw your C
like that if you made it you it'll be
even that way okay but next to this I
want to draw another C looks a little
bit different okay I want to put both
them together and compare them right so
here's the thing I want to draw this
time are you going to be careful how you
draw this one again okay now do you
agree that basically they both the same
shape basically okay now which of the
angles we're interested in they're the
ones in here
yeah and here okay where are they on
this second diagram ii see they're in
the same spot ladies these corners now
look at it carefully right corresponding
angles equal alton angles also equal now
when you look at this one it's tempting
to think they look quite close to each
other but when you look at this other
one is kind of more obvious isn't it
these angles are not the same they're
very not the same this one's blood which
is obtuse so it's sharp which is acute
so how they related to each other
that's okay wait hold on they equal to
180 they add up to what it is probably
the more specific which isn't what you
were saying I think it's what you're
thinking but it's a it's a more specific
way to say it okay now what do we call
these these are Co interior hey why are
they called comment to your young yeah
and then back inside and both of them
inside that's what it came : Terry
angles on parallel lines now we have a
word to describe when things two things
add up to 180 degrees
long awkward word starts with an S we
should just put it sign at the door hey
okay what are we saying
what was the word s supplementary okay
which I think it'd be nice if you put in
brackets after nice they add to 180
degrees I can hold on a second we had a
and a B & B what am I going to put in
here I can't say C and C because that's
their equal right but they're not equal
so how do I say it if I caught for
instance if I call one see what was the
other one B now I could call it I could
call it D right but actually like C and
D are related to each other an important
way namely this they add up to 180 so if
you say C degrees plus some other things
the other angle trying to work out its
equal to 180
that's the supplementary does that make
sense so if I want to know what this
thing is on its own how do I rearrange
it I've got to subtract C from both
sides don't I do you see what happened
subtract C from both sides oh yeah
whatever that angle is right is equal to
180 degrees minus C degrees
see how I subtracted C from both sides
yeah so that's what I'm gonna call this
angle down here I'm gonna call it 180
minus C degrees okay C 180 minus that's
what makes them supplementary okay now
that we know that can we work out these
angles in here for instance what's this
one equal to you could use you could use
any of these you could say this it could
be corresponding to something also to
something or contribute or something
let's say corresponding what's an angle
that's corresponding to this angle down
here
can you name it what angle corresponds
to P why D look at that look at the
diagram and what shape you're looking
for can you name it can you name which
angle should say P why D it is
corresponding to can you name I think
it's P X B can you see it
if I draw like this can you see this an
F then you see that it's just upside
down the x1 okay yeah how are they
related these two angles they're not
correspond my dick on Syria so in the
first place of cinema's corresponding to
this thing up here which means it's
equal does this still make sense on a
coin to your angle supplementary but
they are out there and you can keep
going
oh that's 60 that's 120 as well okay